when it comes to the twin paradox it can
be hard to grasp
just why there are so many explanations
out there on youtube
especially since no two solutions seem
to be the same
in our recent series of videos we've
been taking a deeper look at this
variety of explanations
discussing how they tend to be either
misleading or straight up wrong
and so today we're going to tackle one
of the more sophisticated solutions
this is the inertial frames solution its
proponents
are adamant that it's the only correct
answer to the twin paradox
but does it really resolve the paradox
or is it just a fancier way
of disguising the problem this is
dialect with
do inertial frames resolve the twin
paradox
[Music]
in our last segment solutions to the
twin paradox are still wrong
we tackled several varieties of
incorrect or incomplete explanations to
the twin paradox
we took a look at how space-time
diagrams are misleadingly used
to arrive at a solution we also
performed
all the necessary mathematics to show
that the paradox doesn't lie
in the improper application of the
lorenz transformations
advocates of these methods claim that
the answer to the paradox lies and the
fact that you can distinguish between
the two twins situations
based on which twin accelerates but
there's a second school of thought
that recognizes that this answer is
insufficient
since you cannot accelerate without
first specifying
what you are accelerating in relation to
acceleration is
by definition a purely relative affair
this means that each twin can restore
the symmetry of the paradox
simply by claiming that it is the other
twin who is the one
who is truly accelerating to resolve
this issue
the second tier of videos look for other
ways to introduce
asymmetry into the paradox their primary
fallback is to invoke the concept of the
inertial
versus the non-inertial frame which is
technically what this video from
fermilab does
forget the math and focus on one crucial
difference
observer a existed in one and only one
reference frame
the moving observers existed in two
that's the only difference
originally we were going to review dr
lincoln's video in its entirety
but after watching it we found it to be
so imprecise
and full of misleading statements that
we really can't recommend it to anyone
the video can't even make its own case
in a coherent way
so we're just going to sum it up for you
the claim made by fermilab's video
as well as other proponents of the
inertial frames resolution
is that the symmetry of the twin paradox
is broken
not by acceleration but by the fact that
over the course of the twins separate
journeys
one twin occupies only one inertial
frame
while the other twin occupies two
another way of saying this is that at
some point during the journey
one of the twins inhabits a non-inertial
frame
but what do such statements even mean
what does it mean to
occupy an inertial frame or one of them
versus two of them
or one of them versus a non-inertial
frame
what even defines an inertial frame
most of us understand inertial frames
through comparative examples
say being in a car or train traveling at
constant speed
or occupying a stationary school
laboratory
since these situations are characterized
by their systems being at rest
or traveling at constant velocity it
suggests
that the simplest way to define an
inertial system
is by saying that it is a system which
isn't accelerating
let's see where this definition leads us
with regards to the twin paradox
if twin a sits at earth not moving or
accelerating
she occupies the same inertial frame the
entire time
twin b meanwhile if he travels at
constant velocity
towards the turnaround point reaches it
turns around
and travels back at constant velocity
will occupy two different inertial
frames
one characterized by a plus v velocity
and one characterized by a minus v
velocity
he will also have to occupy a third
non-inertial frame at the turnaround
point
whenever he accelerates or deaccelerates
the fact that he must occupy two
different inertial frames
or equivalently one non-inertial frame
while twin
a occupies only one is according to the
proponents of the inertial frame's
resolution
what produces the asymmetry of the
paradox and results in twin b
being younger seems pretty clear except
that
whoops if twin b sets his coordinate
frame so that he remains at rest at the
origin the entire time
then he will only occupy one inertial
frame while the earth and twin a will
occupy two frames
then twin a will experience the time
dilation and not him in fact
if you define inertial frames via the
absence of acceleration
then to switch between two inertial
frames simply means
to accelerate and the inertial frame
solution
reduces to your basic acceleration
solution
but fortunately proponents of the
inertial frames resolution
are smarter than that their definition
of an inertial system
doesn't rest on the notion of absence of
external acceleration
but rather on the subtler notion of the
absence of external force
twin b who fires his rockets is said to
experience a force at the turnaround
point
and hence occupies a non-inertial frame
during this time while twin a on earth
who experiences no forces remains in an
inertial frame
this difference in experiencing force
versus not experiencing force
produces the necessary asymmetry
required to resolve the paradox this is
what the switching frames resolution
is really all about the whole one frame
two frame formulation is just
kind of a complicated way of saying that
one twin experiences force
while the other doesn't now the
distinction between
force and acceleration is one that most
people get wrong
if you spin yourself in a circle you
have perfect right to say
that everything around you is undergoing
tangential and centripetal accelerations
while you remain at rest this is because
acceleration
like all coordinative descriptions of
motion is only concerned
with relations between specified
reference points
force on the other hand though
identified through acceleration
is assumed to be objective and should
not be able to be transformed away
with a change of coordinates
but there's a problem defining inertial
frames through force
that is as we just mentioned force is
not
an observable and has to be identified
through acceleration
this puts it and consequently the
concept of the inertial frame
squarely back in relative territory
to overcome this you can as we discussed
in our prior video
can you feel force refine the definition
of the inertial frame
once more this time not to indicate
whether or not
your system is experiencing external
accelerations
or external forces but to indicate
whether or not your system
is accelerating with respect to the rest
of the universe
this is for instance how this popular
video on the twin paradox from the ted
ed series
defines the inertial frame to be an
inertial observer
one has to maintain a constant speed and
direction
relative to the rest of the universe but
there's still
a problem with this definition because
if we formulate the twin paradox in
empty space
then there will be no rest of the
universe for the twins to refer to
and thus no way to determine which
twins's frame
is inertial so we have to cross that
definition off too
alright but we can still rescue the
objectivity of the inertial frame
by appealing to another quality about
force
namely that force is always attached to
a source
since in our descriptions of the
universe and our laws of causality
we always require that real
accelerations stem from some physical
source
now here is where we'll split into
different camps about the twin paradox
in the first camp we assume twin a and
twin b
both have extensive knowledge of their
system and can easily identify
the emergence of a force through their
comprehension of its sources
that is if twin b measures twin a as
accelerating
and observes nothing else which could
have produced this acceleration
while meanwhile observing his own
rockets firing and being familiarized
with the nature of his ship's fuel as a
propellant
it will be reasonable on his part to
conclude that he is experiencing force
and therefore that he occupies a
non-inertial frame
he could also make such a deduction by
using an accelerometer
by a haptic feeling of force through his
nervous system
or by noting some other phenomenon whose
behavior he is readily familiar with
people who belong to this camp do not
find such assumptions about
the twins knowledge to be problematic
and so for them
this is the end of the story the paradox
resolves itself here
with the materialization of force
furnishing the requisite asymmetry
needed
to distinguish the twins experiences
their definition of an inertial frame
meanwhile becomes implicitly
characterized
by an absence of any known
force-producing sources
that could be acting on the system
but if like us you belong to the skeptic
camp
then you might see a pretty big hole in
this solution
identifying sources of force requires
studying the behavior of different
materials
across a number of systems this means
your definition of the inertial frame
has to be based
on a certain amount of pre-acquired
knowledge rather than being based
in local observation this is a big
issue think about how it impacts the
twins's situation
if their ability to determine the
inertial quality
of frames of reference relies not on
observation
but rather on a pre-fixed level of
knowledge
then we can easily recover the paradox
simply
by restricting what knowledge the twins
do and don't have
of their environment if twin a for
instance
doesn't have the information to
distinguish whether twin b's
acceleration
was produced by a force or not then she
will be in limbo as to whether or not
she will see him aging rapidly at the
turnaround point
basically this would be like saying that
an observer's reality
would be dependent upon like how much
they paid attention in physics class
in fact if we get rid of the twins
altogether
and replace them with systems of
inanimate particles incapable of
reasoning about the origin of forces
we might ask how is this prior
familiarity with the sources of force
which is crucial for the resolution of
the paradox transmitted at all
that answer would seem to require an
advanced theory of force carrying
particles applicable in accelerated
frames
which we don't have okay we're getting a
little ahead of ourselves
these are more complicated issues we
will be talking about in later videos
for now if you're seeking to understand
the twin paradox at a deeper level
the answer that experiencing force or
equivalently
inhabiting a non-inertial frame is what
breaks the symmetry of the paradox
is certainly a much clearer and more
satisfying answer
than your basic variety acceleration
solution but it definitely leaves
a few stones unturned and leads to
questions that from a philosophical
standpoint
are rather troubling
so keep with us as we continue to
investigate these matters in our future
videos
this has been dialect thanks for
[Music]
watching
you